alguna vez ustedes han sentido miedo
donde su cuerpo no deja de temblar y no
paran de sudar pues yo si es lo que
estoy sintiendo ahorita
bueno pues esto empezó hace 23 años yo
no me encontraba en león y recibo una
llamada a las 2 de la mañana esa llamada
me decían que mi hijo jose pablo de
cinco meses de nacido había fallecido yo
no me encontraba el león
me sentía la peor madre del mundo como
no podía estar con él me jalaba los
pelos brincaba en la cama me encontraba
con mi esposo yo desesperada solo
pensaba que pasó que nadie me sabía
explicar lo que había acontecido
lo único que recuerdo es cuando llegó al
león y me recogió un hermano mío en el
aeropuerto y llegó a la casa funeraria
donde había muchísima gente y lo único
que veo es a mi hijo a mi angelito y
recuerdo verme abrazada de él y decía
porque me lo quitaron porque me lo
permitió tan poco tiempo que hice no no
me sentía como una persona mala que
mereciera ese castigo yo así lo veía
como que si alguien me hubiera castigado
y me hubiera quitado a mi hijo pero
bueno este todo pasó tan rápido tan
confuso que no solo me recuerdo
volviendo a ver a mis hijos porque yo
contaba ya con dos hijos alejandro de
cuatro años y regina de un año y medio
recuerdo que los vi cuando regrese a la
casa de mis padres y al verlos supe que
tenía que volverme fuerte fuerte por
ellos
me volví muy dura conmigo y muy exigente
conmigo pero sabía que tenía que hacer
de esa manera por mis hijos que tenía
que salir adelante de esa tristeza tan
terrible que sentía y claro había días
que no me quería levantar de la cama que
me sentía que no iba a poder vivir un
día más pero gracias a dios tuve un
grupo de amigas mías que fueron desde la
infancia y ellas por tratarme de sacar
de mi depresión iban por mi diario y me
llevaban a correr yo había sido
deportista desde pequeña y ellas sabían
que pues a mí me gustaba hacer ejercicio
entonces ellas por sacarme de mi
depresión pensaron que el correr me iba
a ayudar y efectivamente correr me ayudó
a salir de esa tristeza no no quiero
decir que se me olvidó verdad pero me
fue con una terapia donde corre
me ayudó a mitigar ese dolor tan grande
que yo había tenido este al cabo de un
mes de haber empezado a correr decido
correr un maratón
y claro la gente me decía que estaba
loca que como iba a correr un maratón
con tan poco tiempo que no lo iba a
lograr pero yo mi necedad y quererme
demostrar que yo iba a poder y que era
una persona dura logró correr mi primer
maratón y este y a partir de que yo
cruzo la meta me enamoro de correr sentí
una sensación de paz y una felicidad tan
grande que me dije esto me va a ayudar a
salir adelante al mes de haberme de
haber corrido mi maratón quedé
embarazada y tengo otra hija ella se
llamaba isabella el cual
ella también al principio pues yo tenía
un miedo pavor que tenía muchísimo miedo
este
pues bueno ya cuando me encontraba en lo
más alto de mi carrera dure corriendo 15
años consecutivos 40 maratones cuando me
encontraba en lo top de mi carrera este
tuve una lesión muy fuerte tuve una
fractura de cartílago en la rodilla tuve
tres operaciones y el doctor me dijo que
jamás iba a volver a correr pero yo con
mi necedad y mi tenacidad quería
demostrar que no había imposibles me
sometí a rehabilitación es impresionante
sin 20 rehabilitaciones corría descalza
y a los 5 años después de haber tenido
mis tres operaciones de rodilla logró
correr mi maratón y les demostré a la
gente que dudo de mí que desea que
regina ya estaba acabada que no hay
imposibles cuando alguien se propone
algo lo puede lograr a mí no me podían
decir que había imposibles no yo a pesar
de todo había logrado correr mi mar
y a partir de ahí he corrido ocho
maratones más este he llegado a está
rankeada dentro de las mejores tres del
mundo en mi categoría he ganado el
maratón de houston el maratón de roma
llegué a estar en tercer lugar en el
maratón de berlín y de boston este y
ahora en abril voy a competir el
campeonato mundial este de categorías y
espero llegar a ser la número uno del
mundo este yo tuve varias herramientas
con las cuales me rehabilité dentro de
mi proceso compre una máquina
antigravedad el cual me ayudó para mi
rehabilitación y al ahora y ahora dos
rehabilitación a personas de las cuales
necesitan recuperarse este especialmente
me baso en tengo muchos pacientes
y enfermedades de parkinson y personas
de la tercera edad este para mí correr
se hizo parte de mi vida
a mí al correr me ayudó a mitigar mi
dolor de aquella pérdida tan grande pero
también me ayudó a ser más fuerte a
soportar ese dolor que yo sentía en esos
momentos dentro de la etapa que yo tuve
de esos 15 años consecutivos yo logre
está rankeada dentro de las 10 mejores
corredoras del mundo dentro de mi
categoría y en méxico llegué a estar
dentro de las 10 mejores corredoras de
mexico claro que me tuve que se someterá
entrenamientos muy fuertes donde corría
25 kilómetros diarios este pero no
solamente me dedicaba a correr sino que
también era madre tenía que desarrollar
me como madre tenía una casa que cuidar
tenía
y muchas cosas que realizar dentro de mi
casa entonces yo a mis 55 años les
quiero decir les quiero compartir que
para mí la edad es sólo un número y que
el correr me ayudó a sobreponerme ya
mitigar mi dolor y que cuando uno se lo
propone uno puede lograr lo imposible
gracias
[Aplausos]